so um mcgregor was asked about obi-wan
kenobi season two and here's what he has
to say about it i'm surely up for it
guys i want to do it i'm absolutely
honest there's no plans made yet but i
think i'm pretty sure they're just
binding their time so according to um
mcgregor he thinks personally that
disney will eventually announce obi-wan
kenobi season two but for now they're
just waiting to see how things go now i
personally think there is a good chance
of obi-wan kenobi season two there was
also rumors of this already happening
before the final episode aired and
apparently they even changed the ending
of the kenobi finale for a season two to
happen if you're wondering what change
this was well apparently riva was
actually meant to die at the hands of
darth vader she was meant to return to
him and i think she said that she killed
kenobi and then vader didn't believe it
and then she killed riva now if we do
see kenobi season two my two wishes for
this season like i could probably come
up with more but the first two that come
to mind is i don't want kenobi invader
to meet again and i hope the show looks
a lot better than the first season now
the show did look great in many parts
but to be honest overall it looks like
one of the worst looking live-action
star wars tv shows because when you
compare it to a show like and or just by
judging from the trailer visually that
just looks so much better in regards to
kenobi possibly this is a hot text let
me know in the comment section below but
anyway guys that pretty much wraps up
everything for this video so if you did
enjoy and you haven't subscribed already
please do consider doing so thanks for
watching guys